[Musique]
le département récompense les lauréats
de la troisième édition du concours ne
gaspille un concours qui valorise les
collégiens qui lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire et qui innovent
pour réduire les déchets dans la
restauration scolaire au collège auguste
lacaussade salazie ces collégiens ont
réalisé un menu idéal à menu à zéro
déchet il y avait des amis mozac en
entrée du poulet ou au menu et il y
avait aussi du crumble des papayes du
combat entre en entrée et un chemin de
fer au chaud en dessert et en plus d'un
menu idéal c'est que les gens ont
réalisé des ateliers d'éducation à la
nutrition avec des brigades anti
gaspillage et proposer des assiettes de
petite ou de grosse faim au menu on a
mis en place des différents plans par
exemple le rouge si on a une grande faim
euros le cliché on n'a pas vraiment faim
ou d'initiatives beaucoup de solutions
variées aussi bien depuis la pesée les
tables de tri
des affichages de sensibilisation des
autres élèves et derrière cela donc
former ces jeunes c'est aussi espérer
qu'ils vont être les ambassadeurs
dans leurs établissements autour d'eux
et bien sûr au sein de leur propre
famille le premier prix est attribué au
collège auguste lacaussade le deuxième
au collège de l'étang de saint paul et
le troisième prix revient au collège
paul hermann de saint pierre
[Musique]